[Music]
barberheimer is dominating the theaters
Aquaman is struggling with Batman and
the Meg franchise with Jason Statham is
picking up pace that and much more
awaits you in the latest Kino Czech news
stay tuned
Oppenheimer vs Barbie the battle begins
for months the world has been waiting
for the simultaneous release of these
two opposing films last Friday the birth
of the barberheimer phenomenon on the
one hand there's the historical drama
Oppenheimer by Christopher Nolan three
hours long powerful images partly in
black and white and an enormous cast of
character actors around lead actor
Killian Murphy on the other hand the
brightly colorful ironically funny
plastic Adventure Barbie by Greta Gerwig
starring Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling
two movies that couldn't be any more
different so why are they lumped
together Kevin Kodama from movieweb.com
explains the barberheimer phenomenon as
follows here the beef known from hip-hop
comes into play people love it when two
Rivals compete against each other be it
rappers politicians or Johnny Depp
against Amber Heard You can compare them
discuss wildly about who's better and
last but not least contribute to the
success of your favorite using your own
wallet Oppenheimer and Barbie are
particularly suitable for a fight since
they represent completely different
things gerwig's movie comes across as
particularly feminine modern and
commercial on the one hand it's packed
with cliches while on the other it's
loving and has a positive message no
one's biopic set against the background
of World War II however is shot in an
old-fashioned way and stands for
traditional vintage and masculine Cinema
Oppenheimer was primarily released by
Universal Pictures because Nolan's
long-standing partnership with Warner
Brothers had previously Fallen apart the
main cause was that they released his
film tenet against his will in streaming
at the same time as its theatrical
release rumors spread that Warner
Brothers was taking Revenge by releasing
its pink Barbie toy movie on the same
day as Oppenheimer the ideal scenario
for some proper beef after all hardly
anyone is taking the dispute between the
two movies all that seriously the fans
have shown a sense of humor and produced
countless memes and fan trailers the
actors and directors are posing with
movie tickets for both films and even
the studios will be pleased that
barberheimer has boosted sales so a
happy ending for all involved
Snow White and the Seven Dwarves or not
at least it currently looks like Disney
will give the companions of the
beautiful princess a proper makeover in
the upcoming remake last week leaked
pictures from The Daily Mail did the
rounds they originate from the film set
of the Snow White remake and show a
double of the main character as well as
her seven companions a rather diverse
group of actors of all body sizes skin
colors and genders can be spotted there
is no real sign of classic dwarves which
is Disney's response to the harsh
criticism from Game of Thrones star
Peter Dinklage among others who
described a classic portrayal as being
very backwards film journalist Daniel
Rickman also recently commented on the
leak of the images and even announced
that Disney will completely abandon the
term dwarf in the film instead there is
talk of fantastic beings which
definitely fits the colorful group in
the pictures there will certainly be
some more debate about the Snow White
remake in which West Side Story star
Rachel zegler takes on the lead role we
are eager to find out how Progressive
the story will actually be in the end
and are looking forward to more news
Snow White will be released in theaters
on March 22nd 2024. that's it for Batman
according to the latest reports Ben
Affleck has been cut from Aquaman in the
lost kingdom again marking the latest
chapter in an endless drama surrounding
the new DC movie actually things were
looking pretty good 2018's Aquaman is
one of the most successful DC
adaptations ever am lead actor Jason
Momoa is a veritable fan favorite so
what could possibly go wrong with
Aquaman 2 as it turns out quite a few
things and the production itself is
hardly to blame at first co-star Amber
Heard was a cause for concern as most
people are completely down on her after
the mess she got into with her
ex-husband Johnny Depp to this day it's
not entirely sure how big her role in
the new Aquaman movie will be what came
next was the end of the familiar dceu
and the plans for the new DCU release
dates were changed repeatedly while the
mega flop The Flash was supposed to be
the transition to the new universe in
this context there were several reshoots
for Aquaman 2. at one point Michael
Keaton was supposed to make an
appearance as Batman then Ben Affleck
and sometimes both as The Hollywood
Reporter informs the current presence of
Ben Affleck is now out of the question
following the meanwhile third round of
reshooting the movie is now said to be
entirely Batman free 3. the reason for
this is among other things that DC
boss's James Gunn and Peter Safran want
to let the movies stand on their own for
now without creating dozens of
connections a mistake that was made with
the dceu right from the start the test
screenings of the previous versions of
Aquaman 2 turned out to be very mixed at
times the reactions were quite positive
at other times the sequel was a total
failure one thing is certain the final
version is unlikely to have much in
common with the original one whether the
long ordeal was worth it will be
revealed once the movie hits theaters on
December 20th 2023
one giant shark is not enough in Meg 2
the trench we can look forward to tons
of sea monsters Not only was there new
images to see but the director also
talked about the future of the film
series it all started in 2018 with the
surprise hit Meg directed by John
turtletop the action Blockbuster with
Jason Statham grossed an impressive 527
million dollars on a budget of 130
million dollars so it's hardly
surprising that they wanted to add to IT
director Ben Wheatley who has already
demonstrated his talent for particularly
vicious films with kill list high-rise
free fire took on the task of directing
the sequel in an interview with total
film magazine he talked about his
further Ambitions Meg 3 is absolutely on
his bucket list he believes there is
still a lot to explore in this franchise
he was especially excited by the
international nature of the movie series
here people from the most diverse parts
of the world gathered to face a problem
together which is a fantastic message
for the audience however
viewers are sure to want to see one
thing Above All Else gigantic monsters
in action in Meg 2 Jason Statham Alias
Jonas Taylor and his research team head
for the unknown depths of the ocean
where they clash with a ruthless company
in search of raw materials but the
bigger problem is soon to come as a
multitude of monsters are set loose
which then head for the surface and the
tourists there the level of excitement
for Meg 2 has already risen considerably
since the first trailer new posters now
make us want to see the fun monster
movie even more on one of them not only
do we see that Jonas and the others have
to deal with several Megs at once but
there is also gigantic tentacles
reaching into the picture the Chinese
poster however is really fancy and
presents the film in a very unique style
we can't wait for the release of mag2
the trench on August 4th 2023 should the
movie be able to match the success of
its predecessor a Meg 3 seems highly
likely after all the original book
series by author Steve Alton consists of
a total of eight volumes
fans of Stephen King are about to get
new entertainment after the 2019 remake
of pet cemetery the prequel pet cemetery
Bloodlines is to follow the first images
should now wet the appetite for the
freshly announced release date
Bloodlines is supposed to take place
several decades before pet cemetery and
is based on an unpublished chapter from
Stephen King's novel it tells the story
of young Judd Crandall whom we met in
the first movie as the Creed's family
neighbor in 1969 he wants nothing more
than to leave his hometown however he
and his friends must confront an ancient
evil and dark Family secret that tie him
to the small town forever the newly
released images and poster already given
insight into the atmosphere that awaits
Us in the prequel the starring role of
Judd Crandall will be played by
ambulance actor Jackson white the cast
also includes Jackie Brown star Pam
Greer and the X-Files actor David
Duchovny Lindsey beer who is currently
working on Star Trek 4 and a live-action
adaptation of Disney's Bambi directed
the movie for the first time pet
cemetery Bloodlines will hit Paramount
Plus in the U.S on October 6 2023.
30 million dollars down the drain
Netflix is Calling it Quits and
abandoning its live-action adaptation of
He-Man and the Masters of the Universe
the future of the project is uncertain
it's quite sad Mattel's famous toy world
has been in planning for a remake since
2007. in the meantime Warner Brothers
and Sony came on board and a number of
directors were in talks the project
eventually ended up at Netflix the
directors were to be Adam and Aaron knee
who most recently brought the lost city
with Channing Tatum and Sandra Bullock
to the cinema the leading actor of
He-Man had also already been found in
Kyle Allen pre-production began and a
total of 30 million dollars was spent
turns out it was too expensive for
Netflix
variety reports the streaming giant is
now scrapping everything the total cost
of the production was last estimated to
be around 200 million dollars but
Netflix was willing to provide a maximum
of 150 million including pre-production
it is unclear however whether this is
the ultimate end for the movie rights
holder Mattel still wants to see its
cult classic filmed and is now looking
for new backers with the currently
popular Barbie movie the chances of this
happening are likely not that bad He-Man
and the Masters of the Universe was a
huge hit for the toy manufacturer Mattel
in the 80s and was followed by animated
series and a feature film which by the
way bankrupted the movie distributor
Canon films at the time
so which team do you guys belong to are
you team Barbie team Oppenheimer or
simply both should you be looking for
Alternatives please have a look at our
preview of the new Deadpool movie on our
Channel feel free to share your opinions
and give the video a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it thanks for watching and see
you next week for more kenocheck news
[Music]
oh